all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with spider-verse
and in this instance we are picking up
with the scarlet spider story now
something that i also told you guys is
that we would explain the whole idea
behind like the other and all that kind
of stuff in this video which we will do
but what this initially does is it
basically picks up with like ben reilly
and kane and jessica drew from the
ultimate universe these guys facing off
against genix in all honesty this story
is pretty straightforward and there's
not a whole lot doing here right like
gen x is there to stop them from
destroying the cloning facility their
idea is to destroy the cloning facility
and then things just kind of go from
there right like you basically got kane
and and that's that's kind of the funny
thing i always thought of kane as like
an answer to the question what if the
punisher became spider-man because while
kane is not necessarily as brutal as
like frank castle is he's certainly a
lot more brutal than spider-man
traditionally is and so as a result of
that one of the things that he really
kind of takes on here is this idea that
the inheritors will always hunt them and
where ben reilly is kind of like no no
we can't kill them that's not what we do
the response of kane is like we're past
the point of like the moral high ground
right we're past the point of saying
like we don't kill inheritors because
it's the wrong thing to do instead he's
just like this guy has to die and so
what ends up happening here is that he
actually starts to lose control of
himself and when he does he starts
basically developing like these
appendages and spikes and things like
that that come out of his body and he
successfully kills genix now there's a
reason why this happens and this
basically leads us into our discussion
about the nature of the spider totems
and so on and so forth so here's the
thing to understand when it comes to
these totems the reality in terms of why
marvel created them in the first place
it was initially just designed to
explain why peter parker could do things
that were beyond his normal power set so
originally peter parker was an avatar of
the other then what you also have is the
bride and you have the scion in terms of
the ones that matter here there are
others but the way this all works is
that if we use juggernaut as an example
right kane marco is an avatar of sidorak
insofar as sidorak the demon entity had
a crimson gem and k marco got his hands
on the crimson gem and by possessing it
he is given a portion of the power that
belongs to sidorak the great spider
totems are basically the exact same
thing that you have the multiverse and
then you have the web of life and
destiny which is kind of the spider-man
version of the multiverse so think of it
like the spider-man equivalent of like a
speed force essentially for like the
flash but the spider totems exist on a
multiversal scale and there's only ever
one of them so there's only ever one
other there's only ever one bride
there's only ever one scion right that's
it and the way this works is that you
basically have like the the great weaver
the master weaver if you want to call it
that and their job is to one ensure that
the multiverse is maintained by
basically having individual spider-man
or spider women become hosts for the
great totems or the great avatars and so
in the case of peter parker and the idea
of the other that was initially marvel's
way of explaining how it is he was able
to do things that he couldn't normally
do and it went on that way for a little
while but one of the things that we've
talked about in the past is that when
joe casada became editor-in-chief he
wanted to get rid of what he considered
to be all the unnecessary fluff and
return the characters back to their
basic roots and the basic root of peter
parker is he was a kid bitten by a
spider that basically gave him powers
and then he went forward as spider-man
all the other stuff that like strazinski
and some of those guys did where they
created the spider totems and so on uh
casada thought was unnecessary and so
that's why peter parker who was
originally a host of the other all that
went away in the aftermath of one more
day that when his whole history was
rewritten by mephisto one of those
things is that instead of him embracing
the other as he had previously done he
cast it aside and so that entity that
spiritual essence if we want to call it
that was taken away from peter by the
great weaver and given to cain and
that's why it is that cain is now the
other in marvel comics in the case of
cindy moon she's the bride and in the
case of benji he's the scion now the
question that has to be asked here is
what's the purpose of these guys what do
they do with these particular roles so
if we start with the scion as most of
you guys know whenever a person becomes
like a spider-man or spider-woman more
often than not it's because they're
bitten by a radioactive spider right
this is kind of the mythos surrounding
spider-man and has been since the
character's introduction however there
are occasionally instances where a
person is born with spider powers and
that's what the scion represents
specifically it's binge he's the
youngest person in the multiverse to
have been born with the abilities of
spider-man and so he represents every
instance where a person is born with
spider powers now the nature of silk
also called the bride is she is the one
that's basically the spider wife of
peter parker if we can call that not
literally she's not married to peter
parker but when you look at the various
instances where people have been bitten
by a radioactive spider and then went on
to become spider-man or spider woman it
only ever usually happens once right in
the case of miles morales it's a little
bit different miles morales was bitten
by a spider that came from the same
experimental stock but miles himself was
not actually bitten by the same spider
that bit peter parker cindy moon was
bitten by the same spider that bit peter
parker in the main marvel universe so
she represents random chance right
happenstance the random probability that
somebody will be in a certain place at a
certain time and then be bitten by a
radioactive spider that will turn them
into spider-man and then in turn you
have the other which is basically just
like the warrior quote-unquote of the
various fighter totems right the one
built for conflict and so that's why
over the course of this whole
spider-verse event yes you have all
kinds of different people who have been
bitten by radioactive spiders things
like that but then you have select few
because the circumstances surrounding
them becoming spider-man and
spider-woman are very unique among the
web of life and destiny 99.9
percent of every single spider-man and
spider-woman that you're ever going to
see in the multiverse were just a
version of peter parker man or woman who
was bitten by a radioactive spider and
that's it but benji was born with his
powers silk was bitten by a spider the
same spider that bit peter parker and
the other is the totem that defends all
the others and so in the end in facing
the fact we're facing this revelation
that so long as this cloning facility
remains that it'll just keep going on
and on and on and on with kane currently
knocked out right he's out of commission
and then you've got jessica drew who is
captured by genix then riley does the
only thing he can do right he actually
ends up just activating an explosive
device really just like a giant bullet
right i mean this thing's much much
larger than like a 50 count but
basically just like throws it into a
stack of all these other bullets and
just blows up the entirety of the
cloning facility right he basically ends
up killing himself in the process while
jessica drew gets kane out of there and
as kane begins to come to he realizes
that ben reilly is now dead right ben
reilly sacrifices life in order to
destroy genix and he in turn blames the
inheritors for it and so because of the
fact that he won recognizes that he's
the other two he can kill the inheritors
and three the cloning facility is
destroyed that basically there's no real
way for the inheritors to come back and
so once they die they stay dead and so
basically leaning in to the totality of
his power as the other he heads directly
to loom world in order to find a way to
destroy the inheritors now at that point
we switch over to loom world itself
right back to earth one and you have of
course these other members of the
inheritors who were here right you've
got bora and bricks and you've got genix
or at least what's left of him right the
the last genex that there will ever be
you have like all these people who are
here deimos and so on and they all of
course are just begging for for
forgiveness because of the fact that
they essentially failed solace or at
least in their mind they failed solas
because the different members of the uh
of the totems that are they were
supposed to capture the bride and the
other and so on have all basically
managed to escape but the response to
solace is we're not worried about that
and the reason why is because remember
with the web of life and destiny while
it's not a necessarily guaranteed future
which is do a b and c and d will happen
it's more of if you do a b and c then
like d or e or f will happen or
something along those lines that solace
seems to have this understanding of the
fact that in time because of what
they've done so far specifically the
fact that they've captured benji they've
captured the scion that in turn
everybody else will follow suit right
the nature of spider-man is no man left
behind they won't sacrifice people if
they don't have to and so in turn he
knows they will come to them they'll
basically go to the ends of the earth to
try to find a way to save benji and
ultimately the other and the bride will
inevitably end up on loom world even if
the others stay behind and so what we
end up doing is transitioning back to
earth 3145 right now remember this is
where we discovered that in this reality
uncle ben ended up becoming spider-man
and it's just been kind of laying in
weight here ever since and what we end
up finding out is the origin is not that
dissimilar again kind of tying into this
discussion about like the scion and so
on and so forth that when peter had
basically gone to the science exhibit
that nobody would go with him and so
uncle ben basically took the day off
ended up going with peter uncle ben was
bitten by a radioactive spider and peter
actually leaned into it right he helped
him develop all kinds of like
technologies and things like that that
could help him play this role and that
he basically went forward as a hero the
problem with this is that as you guys
know just by nature of reading comic
books when you are a hero you will draw
the attention of villains and that where
in the main marvel universe the green
goblin had killed gwen stacy in this
universe the green goblin killed peter
parker in aunt may which basically left
uncle ben alone and so he ultimately
abandoned his role as being spider-man
now this is really important because
there was actually a time like this
little panel you see where like uncle
ben is walking away and like the
spider-man costumes in a trash can that
was an actual plot moment that happened
in the spider-man mythos when peter
parker was going to quit he ultimately
ended up going back to be spider-man but
uncle ben didn't do that instead uncle
ben was met by ezekiel sims who
basically told him hey like there are
inheritors running around the multiverse
and they are killing spider-man and they
will find you and kill you unless you
come with me and you stay in this bunker
but unlike what you would expect from
like peter parker of the maine marvel
universe who would do exactly what he
did do which is turn down the offer and
instead go forward as being spider-man
confronting whatever threat may face him
because the lies he can save in the
interim and the good he can do outweighs
the value of his own life that uncle ben
leaned into it and so he decided to stay
in the bunker and where some of you guys
may interpret that as me kind of saying
that uncle ben was a coward the reality
is you would be right and in fact that's
how he's depicted here by dan slott now
one thing that i want to point out when
this happened people were pissed when it
comes to spider-man fans they never want
to see uncle ben shined in any light
other than uncle ben was just this great
guy who always did noble things and his
death was one of the most significant
moments in peter's life but that's kind
of the great thing about this is that
having an uncle ben that makes morally
questionable decisions i think is a cool
thing because it takes him off of this
pedestal that spider-man fans put him on
and kind of brings him down to being
like yeah man he's a person like he's a
human being he's not some godly guy
who's incapable of making bad decisions
and everything he does is great but like
morally questionable decisions that's an
awesome concept and so what you also end
up finding out here is that the world
itself being totally destroyed actually
happened at the hands of otto octavius
now remember superior spider-man is
listening to this whole thing and as you
guys know superior spider-man was when
dr octopus took over the body of peter
and so what superior spider-man is
basically listening to is this story
where an alternate reality version of
himself held the world hostage using
nuclear weapons and that when all his
demands were being met something went
wrong and basically the world evolved or
at least was destroyed by nuclear
weapons superior spider-man is so taken
aback by this because in his mind he
could never make such a miscalculation
and it's one of those funny things
because he's kind of like you know in
every universe no matter what universe
it is i am always this intelligent when
in reality he was kind of an idiot in
this universe
and basically led to it all being
destroyed the other part of this is that
peter parker kind of yanks everybody
back and says okay look this is a cool
tale and everything but it's taking us
off track right our focus needs to be on
what's going on with these spider totems
right what's going on with what the
inheritors want to do jessica drew
sacrificed her teleporter to give us
these scrolls and nobody's ever really
able to read them now when it comes to
silk ever the girl who's emo and just
feels misunderstood by the world when
like somebody makes some offhanded
remark and they're like so basically
jessica drew sacrificed our teleporter
to give us these useless scrolls that we
can't use then silk little miss the
world revolves around me and you know
anytime anybody says anything bad about
something that i happen to be involved
in they're directly talking about me
she's like oh god i feel so bad you know
and that kind of thing i'm sure she
basically leaves one of the things to
understand this story killed people's
interest in silk because all she was was
the girl who just moped around and every
single circumstance that ever went bad
was a reflection of her and the fact
that she had somehow failed as a person
right like people i remember reading the
forms and people were like dude i hate
silk like so much and so what actually
ends up happening is her working
alongside uh spider gwen they actually
teleport away to loom world directly in
order to find a way to get jessica drew
out of loom world and back to basically
this reality which is where none of the
inheritors can arrive to but something
that i hope you guys are noticing is
that now with cindy moon going there on
top of kane going there all the all the
these fighter totems are all in the same
place now one of the other things to
know here is that when it came to uh
anyaka raisin that remember she's not
truly a spider woman per se she is but
she's not she got her powers by mystical
means and the spider society that
worships the nature of spider totems are
the ones who basically gave her her
powers but they also worship the totems
which meant they can read these scrolls
and so anya crazen knows how to read
them because she was taught to and so
where she goes through and reads all
this we're not really given like the ins
and outs and the specific details of how
all the spider totems work but what we
are told is that if the blood of the
bride and the other and the scion is
spilled on the web of life and destiny
then it'll basically destroy any of the
spider totems from coming into existence
that basically there will be no other
there will be no bride no scion or
anything like that and that in doing so
the inheritors will never have to
concern themselves with the other part
of the prophecy which is that the
various spider-man and spider-woman that
exists out there specifically the totems
are destined to end the reign of the
inheritors themselves they're destined
to destroy the inheritors and so that's
why the inheritors are doing this is
because while yes killing various spider
totems does grant them like some
increased level of power and they do
find satisfaction in absorbing the life
energies of various spider-man and
spider women out there their goal is to
actually find the bride and the other in
the scion and then take them spill their
blood on the web of life and destiny and
then destroy the future appearances of
any other spider-man as well as actually
ending the multiverse now this would be
doubly worse because the multiverse is
already collapsing right like the the
incursions were happening at the time
this story was taking place so if
anything the inheritors would actually
speed up the destruction of all
existence which really is one of the
things that a lot of people asked when
it came to spider-verse i found myself
asking that that while you did have like
the black priests and the ivory kings
and all that kind of stuff how come the
inheritors never came across the map
makers or anything like that right if
they were being sent to universes where
spider-man were there it seemed to maybe
kind of make sense because it just meant
that like the incursions had not taken
place on those worlds yet or like the
black priests had not arrived so i guess
it kind of made sense but still you
would have thought somewhere along the
line they would have like met a black
priest or a group of black priests or
something like that and just like fled
for their lives after almost being
destroyed but whatever the case is when
we switch over to loom world where cain
arrives and in fact spider-man tells him
look man like do not go to loom world
and kane's like too late bro i'm already
here right and he's like no no like
you're literally destroying the plan
that we need to create like you're doing
the worst possible thing the question
that spider-man has is or at least a
statement he makes is okay look we
basically got cindy moon who took off to
loom world we've got kane who took off
to loom world the scions already on loom
world they're in the worst place because
they're going to be easy to capture so
he's like everybody doing everything
you're doing drop it right like no
matter what you're doing what it is
that's happening right now drop what
you're doing we all need to go to loom
world and either we have to destroy the
inheritors or we have to save the three
spider totems and get them out of there
and bring them back here now miguel
o'hara's initial response is no like
we're in the middle of something give me
like five minutes and then we'll head
back out there and then of course you
end up having like miles morales and all
those spiderman that they've gathered
who were of course answering the call
and so they're responding and so what
you end up getting or at least doing is
switching back over to loom world and
you basically end up having the having
the other right like kane who
successfully manages to kill solace now
this was another controversial moment in
the story and and when i say controversy
in this story i mean it's i use it as a
loose term right i mean there's nothing
controversial about comic books right
like it's it's comic books but like the
thing about this is that uh that the
other actually kills solace which was
kind of nuts right because again the
other is like the warrior right designed
or destined to face off and seemingly
destroy any threats that may befall the
various fighter totems that exist out
there but where solace who's seemingly
the most powerful of all the inheritors
is killed by kane that in turn kane is
killed by more lun what made this
controversial to fans is that it
happened so incredibly fast right it
just happened so quickly now a lot of
this was because it was just part and
parcel to telling the story so i would
argue anybody who was mad about this was
probably looking for a reason to be mad
to me like i wasn't you know it was like
i mean i guess it makes sense right i
mean something had to happen right i
mean this you know kane couldn't stay
around its spider-man forever in all
honesty this as much as any other story
was designed to kind of wrap up his plot
threads and basically call it a day but
at the end of the day because of the
fact that solace is now dead that puts
more lun in charge of all the other
inheritors and so what you end up
getting of course is that while jessica
drew and cindy moon and spider-gwen are
now gathered together after jessica drew
was rescued by cindy moon and
spider-gwen that in turn released all
the green goblins being sent or being
descended onto them by the inheritor so
of course now they have to flee for
their lies and this leads into another
one of the controversial moments from
the story which was the depiction of
uncle ben that when you switch back to
this reality and you've got peter parker
talking to uncle ben and saying look
like we've got to go the response of mae
parker right this spider girl from an
alternate universe benji's older sister
is like one person is not going to make
a difference and the response of uncle
ben is yeah you're right like i'm not
gonna make any any real difference here
right like i mean i possibly could have
done something to stop you know uh dr
octopus from destroying you know my my
world or whatever it is but he's like at
the end of the day like i'm just one
simple guy right there's nothing i can
do here there's not much that can be
offered to like save this day but this
is where things were really cool with
peter because suddenly the shoe was on
the other foot in years past it was
always uncle ben making these speeches
to peter parker and saying with great
power must come great responsibility
that you have a duty to to things
greater than yourself that you can't
simply just kind of fall to the wayside
collapse in on yourself when times get
hard because it's when times get hard
that you really find out what you are
and the way that uncle ben is depicting
himself is that when times get hard he
gives up he doesn't really like stand up
and kind of keep on going the way that
he's supposed to a massive difference
between this reality's uncle ben and the
uncle ben that peter parker knows and
peter parker goes as far as to tell him
that right like in my universe my uncle
ben never would have done this he never
would have been the guy to just kind of
sit down and collapse and give up roll
over and play dead because things just
got really really hard and because he
made a few bad choices right he's like i
have lost seemingly everything that was
important to me all the things that were
that were that were significant to me
and where peter parker doesn't
necessarily seem to be able to to rile
him up and doesn't seem to be able to
kind of get him back it comes down to
superior spider-man and he's like you're
pathetic old man
and just start screaming at it right
like where peter parker goes to chime in
the response of superior spider-man is
shut up right he's like he's like so
you're saying that's it you're afraid to
fail again right that's what you have to
offer no he's like i've lost more times
than i've won and every time i got back
up that's all that matters and he's like
when victory is easy it's cheap every
fight that's ever been worth fighting
has been against adversity against
so-called quote-unquote unbeatable
forces some kind of unbeatable foe but
there is no such thing every enemy has a
weakness you just have to find it once
right he's the one that actually rallies
uncle ben that gets uncle ben off his
backside and willing to fight again he's
like look the ones who go forward and
achieve great things who do something
meaningful are the ones who stand in the
face of everything they've lost and are
willing to give just a little bit more
in order to get what it is that they
really want and that's what he asks what
is it that you really want here do you
want to give up just roll over and play
dead or do you want to get off your ass
and do something do you want to redeem
all these past mistakes and all these
past failures that you've made and
that's exactly what happens uncle ben
gets up and is like one more time and
dawns the costume and the whole group
goes forward into loom world with the
intention of killing the inheritors with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you guys for
watching
and i will catch you all later
peace